bei uns im studio ist jetzt bild
chefredakteur johannes wo hier ja
johannes die ampel steht aber wo steht
deutschland was bedeutet das für
deutschland
thomas ich glaube zum einen müssen wir
zunächst mal sagen dass das ein
erfreulich und guter prozessor egal was
man inhaltlich von den ergebnissen hält
egal was man von der ampel an sich hält
und dem was uns da jetzt bevorsteht muss
man doch sagen dass das eine relativ
kurzer zeit gelungen ist eine regierung
zu bilden der prozess ist vertraulich
abgelaufen das halte ich zunächst mal
für einen erfolg unserer
parteiendemokratie
was würdest du denn sagen man soll einer
neuen regierung ja natürlich immer erst
mal eine chance geben aber welche
probleme siehst du möglicherweise auch
hier ich glaube was jetzt in den
nächsten vier jahren passiert können
dinge sein die man danach noch einmal
zurückdrehen kann es kann aber auch
themen geben die uns danach weiterhin
probleme machen ein thema das mich sehr
umtreibt ist die migration wir sehen den
großen migrationsdruck nach deutschland
herein wir haben jetzt sehr progressiven
parteien in der regierung insbesondere
bei den grünen und bei der spd ist die
meinung dass man migranten relativ offen
einfach ins land lassen sollte stark
ausgeprägt das kann man aus einer
humanitären perspektive nachvollziehen
aber die erfahrung der letzten
jahrzehnte zeigt eben auch wer erst mal
im land ist der reißt so schnell nicht
mehr aus das heißt das ist ein thema das
uns noch lange begleiten könnte
ansonsten wird sicher das klimathema
sehr viel wichtiger werden das ist etwas
was grundsätzlich zu begrüßen ist hier
sehe ich nur bei der radikalität mit der
manche der beteiligten an das thema
herangehen die gefahr dass es nicht
gelungen wird gelungen gelingen wird
deutschland als vorbild zu präsentieren
auch für den rest der welt sondern dass
es möglicherweise dazu führen wird dass
in deutschland die eigene industrie
stark geschwächt wird so dass sich dann
die aktuellen schwellenländer auch
überlegen möchte ich eigentlich
überhaupt einen weg richtung klimaschutz
gehen guckt mal auf deutschland dort ist
das jetzt wirtschaftlich eine sehr viel
schwieriger situation geworden und man
hat ja eben auch schon in der
vergangenheit gesehen dass die
radikalität bei in den umweltfragen oft
auch zu falschen entscheidungen geführt
hat für mich persönlich zählt dazu zum
beispiel der atomausstieg von dem wir
heute wissen er hätte sehr viel
co2-emissionen zu eigentlich ersparen
können ich hoffe also dass die regierung
gerade in dieser leichen sich keine
fehler machen wird aber ich halte es
leider auch für wahrscheinlich dass es
dazu kommen wird
das sind die inhalte natürlich sind auch
personalien immer wichtig beobachtet man
mit einer gewissen spannung auch wer
bekommt welches ministerium wir können
ja mal die wichtigsten personalien
durchgehend die schon bekannt sind ganz
oben natürlich auf der liste olaf scholz
was können wir was müssen wir von ihm
erwarten es ist ganz schwer zu sagen
thomas olaf scholz ich habe ihn mehrfach
getroffen er beherrscht vor allem die
kunst sehr viel zu reden und dabei sehr
wenig zu sagen
er hat einige skandale die er mitbringt
vor kurzem war noch eine durchsuchung in
seinem aktuellen ministerium dem
finanzministerium über ihm schwebt immer
das damoklesschwert comic skandal
gleichwohl gehört er für mich aus meiner
sicht innerhalb seiner partei bei den
sozialdemokraten zu denen ganz klar
vernünftigen zu den realpolitikern und
ich glaube auch dass olaf scholz einen
relativ vernünftigen plan für
deutschland machen wird er hat es als
finanzminister immer wieder auch
bewiesen denn solche annalena baerbock
chefin des auswärtigen amtes werden was
wie ist deine einschätzung annalena
baerbock hat den vermutlich
katastrophalsten wahlkampf in diesem
jahr hinter sich etwas das sie glaube
ich in ihrer person auch stark
beschädigt hat sie hätte fast kanzlerin
werden können mit all den
vorschusslorbeeren hat es durch eigene
fehler versieht und trotzdem denke ich
wir sollten annalena baerbock eine
chance geben es gibt das eine oder
andere außenpolitische thema da ist sie
eigentlich überraschend gut unterwegs zb
was ihre
konfrontative haltung russland und china
gegenüber betrifft da ist mir persönlich
eine frau berbalk lieber als zum
beispiel ein sozialdemokratischer
minister christian lindner wird
finanzminister werden also das
ministerium dass er sich gewünscht hatte
und hubertus heil ist der einzige der
mutmaßlich übernommen werden wird
sozusagen und sein arbeits und
sozialministerium weiterführen kann von
der spd aber wer kommt noch ins kabinett
ja das ist eine interessante frage die
sozialdemokraten werden dass letzten
endes erst anfang dezember bekannt geben
das heißt wir haben auch jetzt obwohl
wir einige namen haben raum für
spekulationen meine christian lindner du
sprichst ihn an er hat das genial
gemacht als finanzminister hat er eine
enorme hoch halt über die themen die
durchgesetzt werden oder nicht denn er
kann immer sagen das passt nicht ins
budget oder dafür haben wir eigentlich
nach geld ein name der immer wieder
genannt wird jetzt noch bei der spd der
noch nicht gesetzt ist carsten brosda
der hamburger kultursenator als
kulturstaatsminister das ist etwas was
mich bereits jetzt mit wirklich großer
sorge erfüllt ihr wisst dass es im
deutschen bundestag die resolution gegen
boykott der west menschen es gab also
eine klar
israelfeindliche antisemitische meiner
meinung nach organisation und carsten
basta ist jemand der sich dann gegen
diese resolution gewandt hat da würde
ich mich schon fragen wie passt das mit
der deutschen staatsräson dass wir zwar
israel kritisieren können aber immer an
der seite des landes stehen zusammen
wenn so eine person ernsthaft als
kultur-staatsminister gehandelt wird
oder es vielleicht am ende sogar werden
wird jonas projer bild-chefredakteur
danke für die anordnung vielen dank das
sicher sein durfte